okay Beth we're going to interrupt uh
you I'm afraid Lindsay Hoyle is speaking
in the comments in this country that is
why I have suspended the formal business
of the house in order to hear the
president's address
we have also been joined by the Ukraine
ambassador
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have watched the situation unfolding
your country with increasing concern but
also with increasing admiration for the
Courage the fortitude displayed by you
and your fellow ukrainians
Mr President you're welcome to address
members of the House of Commons and the
Lord you now have the floor president
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
I'm addressing all the people of the
United Kingdom
and all the people
from the country with a big history
I'm addressing you as a citizen as a
president
of also a big country
with the dream
and big effort
I would like to tell you about the three
days of about the 13 days of War
the war that we didn't start and we
didn't want it
however we have to conduct this war
we do not want to lose what we have what
is ours our country Ukraine
just the same way as you once didn't
want to lose your country were Nazis
started to fight your country
and you had to fight for Britain 13 days
of this struggle
on day one at four o'clock in the
morning we were attacked by cruise
missiles
everybody woke up people were children
the entire Ukraine and since that we
have not been sleeping
we have all been fighting
for our country with our army
on day two we have been fighting
airstrikes and our heroic military
servicemen on the islands meaning have
been trying to fight
Russian
Flags
when Russian forces demanded that we lay
down the arms
we did continue fighting and
we did we did feel our Force
um the fourth of our people that
oppose their occupants until until the
end
lady the next day the outer artillery
started fighting us
showed us who we are and we we have been
able to see who are people and who are
best
now on day four we started getting
people captive we have not been
torturing them
you remained Humane
even on day four of this terrible war on
day five the terror against us was
going on against children against cities
and constant shelling have been taking
place around the country including
hospitals and that didn't break us
and that gave us feelings
of big truth
on day six
in the Russian um
that is the place where the Nazis killed
thousands of people during the second
World War
uh and 80 years after the Russia coaches
are getting destroyed by shelling
on day eight
dollars we have seen Russian tanks
hitting the atomic power station
and everybody got to understand that
this is the Tara against everyone
on day nine there was a meeting of NATO
Congress
without the
um the result that we were looking for
yes we did feel that
we did feel huge
we did feel that unfortunately that the
alliances don't work properly always
and the no-fly zone cannot be enforced
and on day 10 the ukrainians started
protesting
with their own hands and on day 11.
the children and cities were being hit
and hospitals as well with the rockets
and constant shelling
and on that day we realized that your
ukrainians became Heroes
entire cities children adults
happy and on day 12 the losses of
Russian army exceeded ten thousand
people killed
and also including the general and that
gave us hope
that there will be some kind of
responsibility for those people
of uh in front of the court on day 13.
in the city of marilopo that was
attacked by the Russian Force a child
was killed
do not allow any food any water and
people started panicking
everybody
can hear that
people do not have water over there over
13 days of these
um situation over 50
children have been killed
these are the children that could have
lived
but these people have taken them away
from us
Ukraine we're not looking to have this
form
the Ukraine have not been looking to
become
big but they have become big over the
days
um of this war
the we are the country that are saving
people despite um
despite having to fight the one of the
biggest country one of the biggest
armies in the world
we have to fight the helicopters Rockets
the question for us now is to be honor
to be oh no this is Shakespearean
for 13 days this question
could have been asked but now I can give
you a definitive answer it's definitely
yes to be
and I would like to remind you the words
that the United Kingdom have already
heard which are important again
we will not give up and we will not lose
we will fight till the end at sea
we will continue fighting for our land
whatever the cost
we will fight in the forests in the
fields
on the shores in the streets
I would like to add
that we will fight on the on the banks
of different Rivers like Nepal
we are looking
for
the help of the Civilized countries
we are thankful for this help
and we
agreement
and I'm very grateful to you Boris
please increase the pressure of
sanctions against this country and
please recognize this country as a
terrorist state
and please make sure that our Ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
that well you do what needs to be done
what is stipulated by the greatness of
your country
best of all to Ukraine and to the United
Kingdom
thank you
bye-bye
thank you Mr President on behalf of the
House of Commons I want I want to thank
you for speaking to us and forgiving us
very clearly on powerful perspective the
tragic situation facing you and fellow
ukrainians
we have debated the situation in Ukraine
numerous times in recent weeks and I
know that we will continue to do so and
that when we do so your words will be
resonating with us
I want to express the solidarity of the
House of Commons with you your
compatriots
and we salute the courage of the people
of Ukraine
thank you and our prayers are with you
Mr Speaker
we'll now resume with the formal
sittings of the house order order I will
take the punch border from the leaders
of the main parties before we return to
the opposition day I called the Prime
Minister thank you Mr Speaker
a point of order with your permission Mr
Speaker may I said never before in all
our centuries of our parliamentary
democracy has the house listened to such
an address in a great European Capital
now within range of Russian guns
President Vladimir zielinski is standing
firm for democracy and for freedom in
his righteous defense I believe he has
moved the hearts of everybody in this
house
at this moment ordinary ukrainians are
defending their homes and their families
against a brutal assault and they are by
their actions inspiring Millions by
their courage and their devotion and I
think today one of the proudest boasts
in the Free World is yah Ukraine it I am
a Ukrainian so this is a moment for us
to put our political differences aside
Mr Speaker and I know I speak for the
whole house when I say the Britain and
our allies are determined to press on
to press on with supplying our Ukrainian
friends with the weapons they need to
defend their Homeland as they deserve to
press on with tightening the economic
Vice around Vladimir Putin and we will
stop importing Russian oil Mr Speaker my
right humble friend the business
secretary will update the house on that
tomorrow and we will employ every method
that we can this
and economic Mr Speaker until Vladimir
Putin has failed in this disastrous
Venture and Ukraine is free once more
[Applause]
on a point of order Mr Speaker every one
of us has been moved by The Bravery the
resolve and the leadership of President
zielinski
invading troops marched through his
streets
shells rained down on his people an
assassin seek his life
no one would have blamed him for fleeing
but instead he has stayed in cave to
lead the Ukrainian people and to fight
he's reminded us that our freedom and
our democracy are invaluable he's
prompted the world into action where too
often we've let put Putin have his way
he's inspired the Ukrainian people to
resist and frustrated the Russian war
machine
he has shown his strength
and we must show him and the Ukrainian
people our commitment and our support
labor stands for the unity at home and
abroad that will isolate the Putin
regime
labor stands for the toughest sanctions
that will [ __ ] the Russian state
labor stands for providing Ukraine with
the arms it needs to fight off their
Invaders
labor stands with president zielinski
with Ukraine with democracy
Slava Ukraine thank you they do the SMP
in Blackford thank you Mr Speaker with
you for appearance if I can make a point
of order president zielinski We Salute
You we stand with the people of Ukraine
on the basis of the act of aggression on
the act of War of Putin we must do all
that we can to send support to Ukraine
to send the weapons that they need to
defend themselves
to make sure that we sanction the regime
in Moscow that we deliver the cleanest
message to President Putin that this
will end in failure for him that he will
face Justice at the international Court
we must stand in this house
throughout these islands throughout the
Western world
and defense of democracy
in defense of sovereignty
peace Justice and the sovereignty of
Ukraine
must prevail
let's make sure that we stand with our
friends we stand against those that have
been bombed
we make sure that those that need our
support that need our sanctuary
will find a welcoming hand at these
islands
Mr President
we thank you
We Salute You
slavia Ukraine and David point of order
Mr Speaker hearing the words of presence
lensky should embolden us all
they serve as a reminder of all that we
stand for of all which so many
ukrainians are so bravely fighting for
a bravery exemplified by President
zielinski himself but we should never
take for granted our values of democracy
of freedom and of our security
and though we in this house may disagree
on many things we stand together for
those values and together we stand
together with the Ukrainian people
Mr Speaker it is right that we
strengthen our support for Ukraine
with military aid with toughest of
sanctions and it's in that support that
we should also recognize the people of
Ukraine and indeed president silenski
I'm sure the whole house would agree
that President zelenski should be
granted one of our nation's highest
honors an honorary Knighthood and I look
forward to the day when we welcome back
to this house president zielinski in
person
yeah so Jeffrey Donaldson thank you Mr
Speaker on a point of order we command
president zielinski and the people of
Ukraine and we stand with them in this
uh their time of strife but our response
will not be judged by the volume or
strength of our Applause for president
zielinski it will be judged by the
volume and strength of our response to
his request for help for practical
military support and for humanitarian
assistance for the people of Ukraine we
pray for their success we dare not let
them down
yeah
can I also like to thank the staff and
the contractors for making this happen
well there we are we've just witnessed a
remarkable event in the House of Commons
an unprecedented event in the House of
Commons president zielinski of Ukraine
getting a standing ovation before he had
even said a word
um
when he did speak he said I would like
to tell you about the war we didn't
start and didn't want and he likened it
to Britain's fight in the second world
war he gave a day by day account then of
the invasion saying
um they had faced missiles and
airstrikes but his forces were resisting
he talked about the sieges of the cities
where civilians are still suffering as
we speak and uh he said the question now
is to be or not to be and he said it
will be to be
he said we will not give up we will not
uh end this uh with uh failure we will
fight he said to the end and he invoked
really a kind of churchillion spirit in
the speech and to Boris Johnson he said
please increase sanctions and recognize
it as a terrorist State talking about
Russia and then Boris Johnson said the
house had never heard such an address as
this he said Britain and our allies will
press on with delivering weapons press
on with sanctions and with every method
we can make to make sure Putin fails
well our political editor Beth Rigby was
listening to all that and Beth an
extraordinary event in the House of
Commons
it really was Mark it was a very moving
moment MPS on their feet the Applause I
could hear it outside the chamber it was
it was deafening and president zelensi
there as you were summing up with such
dignity and courage going through these
13 days of Wars you said a war that the
ukrainians did not want and there was
Echoes of Churchill in that address as
he said we will not give up we will not
lose we will fight in the forest the
fields on the shores in the streets and
then a plea to allies to the UK
government to other G7 countries and of
course NATO he said we're looking for
help of civilized countries he said I'm
grateful to Boris and he said please
increase sanctions and recognize this
country as a terrorist State and make
sure our skies are safe so much in that
address but look I am joined Now by
Former Defense secretary Dr Liam Fox let
me ask him what he thought of the
address we're just trying to get the
mics going let me move that for you Liam
sorry we should do this on the Hop
um
how did it how did it fit how how did it
feel in in the Commons I thought it was
tremendously dignified performance by
the president very courageous as you say
setting out the impact that the war has
had on the people of Ukraine but also
asking the Free World to continue their
support to continue helping not just
with the supply of weapons that they
need to fight off the atrocities of the
Russians but also tightening the
sanctions and I think perhaps the most
moving thing was he said in a reference
to the existential nature of this war he
said to quote Shakespeare we have to
choose as a country to be or not to be
and we choose to be
said we choose to be he said we will not
give up he said we will win but do you
honestly think that the ukrainians with
all the heart that they have can win
this war without direct military
intervention from NATO yes and I think
that people are underestimating to some
extent the actions that the whole world
has taken against Russia when you get
countries like Switzerland giving up
their neutrality to put sanctions on
Russia you get an idea how United the
international response has been and the
the uh potentially crippling action
taken against the Russian Central Bank
will produce real economic hardship in
Russia very quickly and I think that
ultimately Putin has to decide uh is is
this about his ego about his view of
History his Reclamation of the Soviet
Empire and he's willing to see not only
death and destruction in Ukraine but
potential appalling hardship and the
destruction of his own economy at home I
mean what what sort of Madness is this
and Dr Fox just in in that statement
president zielinski again made a plea
please keep our skies safe the no-fly
zone what's your your former Defense
sector you are a foreign policy expert
what's your view of that request well
you couldn't have a no-fly zone unless
you had commit created a permissive
environment in other words we would have
to bomb any Russian anti-aircraft
facilities to make sure our Pilots were
safe that would bring us into direct
conflict with Russia if people want a
war that's the way to go about it and
there is there is a war yes but you're
talking about a full European War NATO
against Russia Not only would does that
not only does the talk about that
heightened the tension but it actually
plays into Putin's narrative Putin wants
this to be portrayed in Russia as Russia
against NATO
we've got to show that this is Russia
hitting its might against a defenseless
and harmless Ukraine we've got to make
sure that people understand the
malevolence and the wickedness of what
Putin is doing here and the scale of the
destruction and death he's bringing to
innocent people we mustn't give them the
excuse to turn it into something else so
you agree with the position of of not
having a no-fly zone I know some of your
colleagues think differently if if we
don't intervene NATO doesn't intervene
uh directly and the sanctions are the
tool with which pucin finally fails how
do you see this playing out is this a a
month two months many months many years
how long are we going to have to watch
this awful situation unfold in Ukraine
well first of all the Russians don't
have Supremacy in the skies in the way
that many people thought they would it's
very clear that their Logistics are not
very good it's very clear that they
didn't expect the resistance of the
ukrainians that they have so so however
long Putin has been thinking about this
he hasn't prepared very well or hasn't
understood the conditions he would face
most of the damage being done in Ukraine
is being done by shelling by artillery
and if we're able to supply ukrainians
with defensive equipment and offensive
equipment so much the better but the
question of how long really depends on
how much Putin is willing to see pain
not only inflicted on Ukraine but
increasingly severe pain on his own
people I mean the evidence to date is he
doesn't much care about his own people
but his people themselves make it
and just final question what's your view
on the government's handling of this the
Prime Minister has of course been on the
world stage but in terms of the refugee
policy and also the sanctioning of
Russian oligarchs some criticism from
his own back benches well I think that
we have been on the front foot Britain
was at the Forefront of leading the
economic sanctions including the uh the
sanctions against the Russian Central
Bank which I think is the most crucial
of all I think when it comes to the
humanitarian question we've understood
that when it comes to trying to stop
Putin in Ukraine we have to act as an
International Community we have to do
the same on the humanitarian front a lot
of these refugees they're not economic
migrants they don't want to come to
other countries the chances are they
will want to stay close to the borders
of their own country so they can go home
join their families or communities
in the way that we would all want to do
that's going to produce a huge pressure
on the governments of Poland or Slovakia
of Hungary and of Romania in particular
and we have to recognize that we have to
help them in every way that we can I'm
going to Poland tomorrow I'll get a
chance to talk to people more there but
whatever happens I think we need to
recognize that although this war is not
happening on our geographical borders is
happening on our human borders thanks Dr
Fox thanks for joining us and you should
come back and tell us how your visit to
Poland work thanks for coming on Sky
News uh Mark there you have the former
Defense secretary quite clear that uh
imposing a no-fly zone would put NATO
into direct conflict with Russia and
then this war is not just between UK
Ukraine and Russia but between Europe
and Russia something that he argues the
West cannot countenance so uh president
zielinski is very very passionate
heartfelt address but for now it's still
a question of sanctions although the
energy sanctions today just announced by
the US the EU the UK all very
significant
yeah sanctions and supplies of defensive
military equipment Beth thank you very
much indeed let's speak to our security
and defense Senator Deborah Haynes who
is here in Western Ukraine uh with me
this evening and Deborah we heard there
um president zielinski saying this is a
fight we can win what is the reality on
the ground militarily this evening as we
speak
well I mean the reality is that the
Ukrainian military is still holding its
own it is against the expectations of
Russia and also Western allies even has
managed to prevent Russian forces from
taking any really significant territory
on day 13 but it's been at a huge cost
and you can hear day by day as each day
can as each day goes by and as the war
continues
um the the language coming from from the
president from his advisors from his
ministers is increasingly impassioned
when it comes to wanting their Western
allies to do more to stop the bombs and
the artillery and the missiles from
raining down on cities across the
country and I think that is what you're
going to see going forward it's this
increased humanitarian cost that's being
imposed by Russia upon Ukraine and
you've also had that you know we've had
this very small humanitarian Corridor
opening up for one city today in the
Northeast the city of Sumi but in cities
like mariopol in the Southeast an
attempt for a humanitarian Corridor
there stopped because of selling and as
when that happens you've got people
there literally running out of food
water medical supplies it's desperate
but in terms of the actual battle the
military side of things the Ukrainian
armed forces have managed to deal
significant losses on the Russian side I
mean the president in his address there
he talked about there being more than 10
000 Russian military personnel killed
that's a Ukrainian tally and we haven't
heard what the Russian side says in
terms of the latest number of Russians
killed but there's a definite fact that
Russia is suffering a huge loss but as
that happens they are ramping up the
level of force that they're using
against Ukraine and that is when the
civilian toll increases and also the
ability for Ukraine's military to hold
out is only finite which is is why the
weapons coming in from the West is so
important but like you've mentioned with
Beth that whole question about a no-fly
zone there's a very thin line that NATO
is trying to tread at the moment they've
made very clear that they are not going
to intervene directly but the level of
indirect support that they're giving to
Ukraine is increasing and whether it
reaches a threshold whereby Russia
actually turns around and thinks they're
effectively in direct confrontation
regardless that that remains to be seen
and that that too becomes more and more
dangerous as you're looking to try to
contain this conflict within Ukraine's
borders the ability to do that weakens
the longer the conflict here continues
okay Deborah thank you very much indeed
and just before President zielinski
spoke we were talking to a family in
Kiev uh Vladimir ariev a politician
um in Kiev also his daughter yarina who
is with her husband uh Seattle who well
they just got married a few days ago
right at the beginning of uh this war
and have both signed up to help the
volunteer Defense Force a quick word we
had a quick word with you before
um Vladimir
um are you happy with what uh well
president zielinski is asking again for
more help are you happy with the help
that you're getting from the West
well I can join the zelensky speech
especially when he said that we will
fight everywhere where possible to beat
out Invaders and I'm really grateful to
United Kingdom United States uh Baltic
states uh that's supplied by Ukraine
with m-laws javelins and other women to
beat out uh Russian aggression on the
first stage uh I can understand that
NATO is not very decisive in the measure
of close the sky over Ukraine uh been
afraid to be involved uh as a third part
of the conflict but Russia will do its
utmost to make NATO a third part of of
this conflict because Ukraine I'm pretty
sure this is a not an only not the only
a goal so we are we we should understand
that now uh we are we are fighting for
all Europe and uh we are fighting uh not
only for our uh Independence that is
vitally important uh for us uh this uh
supplying of Air Defense Forces and are
there very necessary things that could
be discussed uh between uh Ukrainian
Minister of Defense Ukraine Minister of
Foreign Affairs with Western uh about
with our Western partners and we should
of course the these sanctions uh like uh
the Embargo on and try energy trading
oil and gas with Russia as a barrier
State it's very important extremely
important now but at the same time at
the same time uh I would like to to
address to the whole world if it's
possible no one after this new reality
can cannot stay aside of that because if
Russia succeed in Ukraine